- HEY, ALICE?
CAN WE, UM, HAVE A MINUTE?
- FINE.
- UH, HOMEGIRL'S DEATH, IT--
IT'S GOT US, UH--
WE'RE--WE'RE PRETTY BUTTHURT
ABOUT IT.
- REALLY?
- YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO COME IN
TOMORROW AND JUST
PLUCK AWAY
AND DO OUR DUTY HERE,
BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M GONNA SOUND OKAY
[high pitched]
ON THE PHONES, BECAUSE I CAN'T--
- YOU SEE, HE JUST NEEDS
A DAY TO GRIEVE...
- YEAH.
- HAVE A GOOD CRY.
WE ALL JUST NEED A--
PROBABLY A GOOD CRY.
JUST A DAY. ONE DAY.
- YOU WERE GONNA CRY TOO,
THOUGH, RIGHT?
- NO, I'M--I'M PROBABLY GONNA--
- SEE, HE'S CRYING TOO NOW.
- YEAH, OKAY, SO IF
YOU GUYS WERE ACTUALLY UP--
- ALICE! HEY, WHAT'S UP?
I--IT'S AWESOME TO, EH,
RUN INTO YOU HERE.
I WAS JUST OUT THERE,
INDIVIDUALLY TALKING
WITH EVERYONE,
AND WE ALL AGREE THE BEST WAY
TO COMMEMORATE HOMEGIRL'S LIFE
AND REMEMBER HER IS BY
IMMEDIATELY FORGETTING HER,
AND JUST WORKING
ALL DAY TOMORROW.
- OKAY, ADAM,
DON'T MESS THIS UP FOR ME.
YOU KNOW HOW I AM WITH GIRLS.
I'M LIKE A BULL
IN A VAGINA SHOP.
- BLAKE, IT'S NOT MY FAULT
YOU'RE NOT
A RICO SUAVE DUDE, OKAY?
- I AM A RICO SUAVE--
- YOU ARE NOT A RICO SUAVE--
- OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
THAT IS ENOUGH.
OKAY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU GUYS ARE UP TO,
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT "BUTTHURT" MEANS.
BUT GUESS WHAT.
DEATH HAPPENS,
AND IT'S REAL SAD.
AND WE'RE ALL STILL COMING
INTO WORK TOMORROW.
- YES! WE'LL GE--
- SHOULD WE NOT REMEMBER
HOMEGIRL BY AT LEAST
HAVING SOME SORT OF SERVICE
FOR FRIENDS, AND CO-WORKERS,
AND OUT-OF-TOWN GUESTS?
- I DON'T NEED THIS.
- OH, YES.
THAT WOULD BE
VERY GOOD.
- OKAY, FINE.
TOMORROW, AFTER LUNCH,
YOU CAN HAVE A THING.
- THANK YOU.
- WE DON'T NEED A THING.
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- THIS IS NOT FA--
ALICE, THIS IS NOT FAIR!
I AM HAVING THE WORST DAY
OUT OF EVERYONE
IN THIS ENTIRE OFFICE...
EXCEPT--EXCEPT MAYBE HOMEGIRL.